eric swanson is up on the mound for just
the second time of this young season and
his first start since way back in 2019
his first tour in the big leagues it's a
bullpen night for the mariners so we'll
see how scott service and company can
piece it together in back of swanson
they're hoping that he can record six
outs
before turning things over to the rest
of the pin tonight so here's cedric
mullins swung out in a fly ball into
left field back it up
and right there is taylor tremell to
make the catch and there's one away as
mullins flies out here's austin haynes
here's the stretch and the 0-2 on the
way here she comes and it's strike three
called on the outside corner with a
slider so swanson very quickly with his
first strikeout of the night two outs
for the orioles here in the top of the
first inning
and that'll bring up first baseman trey
mancini swinging a fly ball into right
field hanegar drifting back near the
warning track toward the corner he's
there and makes the catch and that'll
end the inning so a nice start for eric
swanson now dean kramer taking the
mountain making his fifth start for the
orioles this year oh and two with an 8.4
earned run average 15 innings 14 earned
runs six walks 18 strikeouts for kramer
here's mitch haniger to lead things off
there's his swing line drive right field
but right at austin hayes he makes the
catch for out number one no score bottom
of the first and here's designated
hitter ty france there's a swing fly
ball shallow center field going out
valencia in comes mullins valencia peels
away and mullins makes the catch for the
second out of the bottom of the first
and kyle seeger coming up to the plate
it's up high for ball four so seeger
with a two out walk kyle on at first
base no score in the game and that'll
bring up center fielder kyle lewis
swinging a ground ball up the middle
into center field for a base hit kyle
lewis
with the mariners first base hit of the
night and now the mariners have runners
at first and second with two down and
here is first baseman jose marmaleos
swing and a fly ball left center field
mullins ranging over calls mount castle
off catch is made and the inning is over
so kramer allows a couple of two out
base runners but no damage done
designated hitter michael franco leading
off the top half of the second here's
the 2-2 on the way and it's strike
recall another great slider from eric
swanson he strikes out franco looking at
his strikeout number two for eric one
away for the orioles here in the top
half of the second here's ryan mount
castle scoreless game swinging a ground
ball two hopper to third waiting for the
big hop seeger he's got it toss across
in time to get mount castle for the
second out of the inning so that's five
in a row to start the game retired by
eric swanson that'll bring up shortstop
freddie galvez slider check swing down
and indeed he go yes he did and he gets
the strikeout there is eric swanson's
third strikeout early in the ball game
he retires the first six batters he
faces in a row second baseman dylan
moore leading off the bottom of the
second 2-2 pitch
curve ball popped up
foul ground third base side
severino going over to the orioles
dugout does he hang on yes he does pedro
severino
goes over to the front of the orioles
dugout he was at the railing lost his
cap and made the catch
jumping up into the air and going into
the netting adjacent to the dugout well
done pedro severino going to get dean
cramer now send up the former philly jp
crawford swing and a miss went to the
cutter back door that was a beauty and
jp crawford didn't stand a chance in
that effect that is strikeout number one
for kramer there's his swing fly ball
crank to center but mullins has got it
measured he walks in looking skyward
makes the catch in medium center field
and cramer a clean and easy second
inning all with two outs malaika got it
started single to right mullins followed
with a line drive single to right and
now the walk to hayes loads them up for
tray mancini he's been hitting really
good and over the last 14 games he's
hitting 333. swinging a miss strike 399
at the knees domingo tapia throws 20
pitches all fastballs
and he leaves him loaded dean cramer too
scoreless so far the one-two pitch to
tremell it's a swing and a miss strike
three the ball gets away from severino
he retrieves it he throws to first base
and they get the speedy trammell second
punch out for kramer see us face the
order one time through franco advances
to third they had a lead off double here
in the fourth and they're trying to
punch one through here it's going to be
up to pedro severino swing and it's
popped up first base side foul territory
coming over his best he wants it so does
marvoleos and marvaleos will make the
catch and that'll end the inning
at second base austin hayes now the
batter and drew steckenrider has come on
inheriting just a little bit of traffic
in a scoreless time strike three called
with a fast ball he burns the inside
corner strikes out hayes and that's it
for the birds in the fifth and dean
cramer has brought his a game to the
hill he's been terrific first four
innings he's only allowed one hit four
shutout innings best ball strike three
inside edge that was a beauty over the
corner 94 miles an hour dean kramer just
absolutely carved him up in this at bat
one away and here's catcher tom murphy
there's a swing and a fly ball into
right field hayes going back to the
woody track near the wall leaps up and
it's gone
goodbye baseball tom murphy with an
opposite field home run mariners have
the lead one to nothing here in the
bottom of the fifth inning question is
will dean kramer have any scar tissue
because of that swing right can he get
back into the groove and flush it swing
and a miss trammell twice his strikeout
victim now as kramer pumped to fastball
buy him his fourth k at the end of the
evening i think this is probably going
to be his last inning and you'd love for
him to get through six here's a line
drive in the left back goes mount castle
makes the catch dean kramer six innings
a one run baseball and the orioles put
the tying run on base
orioles need some offense running out of
outs here as mullins getting an
opportunity to face
a left-handed pitcher which has been a
specialty
for him this year swung on in the fly
ball deep into the gap in the right
center field hannah racing back to the
woody track to the wall leaps up and he
makes the catch
holy smokes he got it does he have it no
he doesn't it's gone the orioles take a
two to one lead it looked for a second
like mullins had been robbed at the wall
it was off his glove and over the wall
mullins does it again against a
left-handed pitcher and he puts the
orioles on top of the eight one out and
a runner at third michael franco is due
up next makes contact
they throw to first and look at falco
he's excited he got his job done an rbi
and the orioles now have a three to one
lead and the inning continues galvez
will be the seventh man to hit in the
inning there's his swing and a rip deep
left center field giving chase's lewis
and this ball he's out of here it's a
two-run homer for freddie galvez they
lead it five to one
mariner comebacks it seems like they
always start this way with a walk or two
right never know one on and one out and
the better is mitch haniger swinging a
drive deep to left field mont castle
going back looking up goodbye baseball
it's now the orioles five and the
mariners three cesar valdez coming on
the mariners are down to their final out
swing and a miss throws to first ball
game over the orioles take it five to
three over the mariners